WE'RE SPEAK NOW TO CHASTEN
BUTTIGIEG.
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED IN COLORADO
SPRINGS AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THESE FAMILIES, HOW ARE YOU
DEALING WITH IT?
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO YOU THIS
MORNING?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, IT'S TOUGH.
IT'S HARD AND IT'S DEFINITELY
HARD BEING IN A POSITION TO
WATCH PEOPLE CONTINUOUSLY ATTACK
YOUR COMMUNITY.
AND IT HAPPENED RIGHT AFTER
PULSE OUR COMMUNITY WAS
SHATTERED.
AND SEEING THIS HAPPENING AGAIN
AND SEEING WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE RHETORIC SURROUNDING IT IS
CERTAINLY PAINFUL.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT THE
RHETORIC SURROUNDING IT BECAUSE,
LISTEN, ESPECIALLY LATELY A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN USING GAY
PEOPLE -- NOT JUST LATELY BUT IT
RAMPED UP DURING THE MID TERMS,
USING GAY PEOPLE AS POLITICAL
PAWNS IN THEIR MESSAGING AND
THEIR ADS AND THINGS THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET ACCOMPLISHED AND
TRYING TO ROLL BACK CERTAIN
ISSUES.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> YEAH.
CERTAINLY IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE
WATCHING THEM TRY TO HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS.
THEY SPENT THE ENTIRE MID TERMS
AND FOR MANY OF THEM THEY SPENT
THEIR ENTIRE TIME HERE IN
WASHINGTON ATTACKING THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY, ATTACHING TERRIBLE
LABELS TO LGBTQ AND THEN
SOMETHING LIKE CLUB Q HAPPENS
AND THEY WANT TO SEND US THEIR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS.
I KNOW PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
WORDS HAVE POWER AND THEY HAVE
CREATED A VERY DANGEROUS
ATMOSPHERE FOR LGBTQ PEOPLE WITH
THEIR LANGUAGE.
AND THEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS AND THEY QUICKLY JUMP ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND SAY THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS.
HOW AWFUL.
THEY CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS AND
THEY NEED TO WAKE UP AND
UNDERSTAND THAT IDEOLOGY AND
THEIR RHETORIC AND LANGUAGE IS
HURTING PEOPLE.
>> WHAT TO YOU SAY TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE FRUSTRATED
WITH THE HATE OUT THERE?
>> I SHARE IN YOUR FRUSTRATION.
BUT I ALSO WANTS TO SAY I
BELIEVE THAT FOLKS ON THE MAGA
RIGHT, THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THESE MEGA PHONES ON SOCIAL
MEDIA OR HERE IN CONGRESS ARE A
VERY, VERY VOCAL MINORITY.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND AND
REMEMBER THAT THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE IN LGBTQ
EQUALITY, THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS ARE WITH US.
THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
BELIEVE IN MARRIAGE EQUALITY.
BELIEVE THAT TRANS PEOPLE SHOULD
BE PROTECTED AND RESPECTED.
THESE FOLKS JUST HAVE REALLY BIG
MEGA PHONES ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S GOOD TO REMEMBER NOT
EVERYONE IS SPENDING THEIR DAYS
ON TWITTER, ON FACEBOOK.
THEY'RE GOING ABOUT THEIR LIVES.
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON GETTING THINGS DONE
OR COMING TO WASHINGTON AND
COMING TO SOLUTIONS ARE JUST
FOCUSING ON US.
>> NORMALLY I DON'T LIKE TO GIVE
THINGS LIKE THIS OXYGEN, BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE, ONE, IT'S HAPPENING
AND, TWO, YOU RESPONDED TO IT
AND IT WAS A DIRECT CRITICISM
AND ATTACK ON YOUR HUSBAND.
THIS IS FOX NEWS'S TUCKER
CARLSON ATTACKING YOUR HUSBAND
AND ABOUT THIS TRAGEDY.
WATCH THIS.
>> PETE BUTTIGIEG WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT IDENTITY.
HE ALWAYS WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
IDENTITY.
THE FUNNY, IRONIC THING IS,
UNTIL A FEW YEARS AGO, BUTTIGIEG
WOULDN'T ADMIT HE'S GAY.
HE LIED ABOUT IT.
NOW HE'S HAPPY TO SUUSE HIS SEXL
ORIENTATION AS A CUDGEL TO BASH
PEOPLE WITH IT.
>> YOU RESPONDED WITH THIS POST
OF YOUR HUSBAND WAVING IN HIS
MILITARY UNIFORM.
WHAT DID YOU MEAN IN THAT
PICTURE IN.
>> MY HUSBAND SERVED UNDER DON'T
ASK, DON'T TELL, WHICH MEAN HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN DISCHARGED FROM
THE MILITARY IF HE HAD COME OUT
OF THE CLOSET.
IN THE CLIP TUCKER CARLSON SAYS
MY HUSBAND JUST WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT THAT AND NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THIS KIND OF RHETORIC IS SO EASY
TO ATTACK PEOPLE AND TO GO ON
YOUR TALK SHOW AND FIRE PEOPLE
UP ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
I LOVE MY HUSBAND DEEPLY.
I KNOW HE'S A COMMITTED PUBLIC
SERVANT AND HE EVERYONE'S BEST
INTEREST AT HEART.
I JUST THINK THESE PEOPLE AGAIN
WITH THESE MEGA PHONES, THEY
HAVE A BIG PLATFORM.
RATHER THAN FOCUSING ON REAL
ISSUES, PEOPLE'S LIVES, MAKING
THEM BETTER, THEY'VE DECIDED TO
FOCUS ON HATE.
>> LISTEN, I LIKE TO FOCUS ON
THE REALITY OF AMERICA AND THAT
IS THERE ARE MEMBERS, GAY,
LESBIAN, BISEXUAL COMMUNITIES,
THEY ARE HAVING GREAT
INTERACTIONS WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND TALKING ABOUT ALL OF THESE
ISSUES.
I AM A FAMILY LIKE THAT.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TWINS NOW.
I'M WONDERING HOW YOU SPENT YOUR
THANKSGIVING, WAS IT GREAT, DID
THEY EAT TOO MUCH?
>> THEY CAN POLISH A PLATE QUITE
WELL.
WE HAD A LOVELY DAY.
NE
THEY ARE WALKING AND TALKING AND
MOST BEAUTIFUL HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU BUT THERE
AREN'T WORDS YET.
WE'RE DESTROYING EVERYTHING WE
CAN GET OUR HANDS ON.
IT'S LOVELY TO HAVE THIS TIME TO
SPEND TOGETHER AS A FAMILY.
WITHOUT BRINGING TOO MUCH
POLITICS TO IT, I KNOW WE'RE ON
THE PRESS MISS OF A MARRIAGE
EQUALITY VOTE.
FOR ANY SENATOR WONDERING
WHETHER THEY SHOULD VOTE YES OR
NO, SPEND SM TIME WITH US
LATELY, EATING A GOOD MEAL AND
AND, LISTEN, I THINK IT'S
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOUR FAMILY.
I KNOW THAT IT'S TOUGH WHEN YOU
TO TALK ABOUT THESE SOCIAL
ISSUES INDEPENDENTLY OF THAT BUT
I WOULD THINK IN THIS DAY AND
AGE, THEY WOULD DEFINITELY SAY
IT WAS NECESSARY.
BEST OF LUCK TO YOU, HAPPY
THANKSGIVING AND WITH REGARDS TO
YOUR HUSBAND AS WELL.
>> THANK YOU.